get it and you have to do it
slow right
you know ease up here so the first boot
okay
right in the garage
seek a grip
you see what I'm doing they're changing
they're changing position
don't have me go around you
yeah okay
I want them to learn
then think of you can ignore this hand
if you're gonna go this way and you're
worried about this well get that angle
cancellation on the side that you're
going to so if I want to be on his right
side then I need to make sure that this
elbow is going that way okay
don't leave it there you're doing a
shoulder parry on that elbow and just
enough to hit back here that's your
normal chemo maza right this one he's
she got in here
try it when he goes home he can't move
my head do you understand
move my head backwards I'm gonna step
before I lose it you got it he's not
gonna break my Center whoa
you understand I'm holding that that's
how I that's how I do everything I'm
walking around comes in all right cool
that's how I'm striking so that's why
that's when I get hit line - oh hey you
guys are breaking Center try it again
I'm not gonna go here my whole bond is
boomed you see how I did that
not here hey dude up close oh I'm still
moving through don't let them have their
face back
yeah so I'm you know like that magic
powder base back I continually keep the
angle of disturbance going hey okay
you don't want to push so that you get
him going straight back you see that we
trying to attack his corner so you want
this to turn got it
so no push where is math it push where
that corner boom ha okay who should I be
done you got the boom and I just move in
I hope I have to check this hand because
I don't want it to fly up when I end up
in the face okay so I just am NOT
pinning it I'm just making sure it
doesn't fly up you see that I got just
relax here and then my strike square up
again it's going to come up underneath
this chin and take his head out of his
punch do you understand that so I'm not
trying to knock him out maybe he knocked
me out instead I'm trying to deconstruct
his punch okay so when he goes pool
so his he his chin has to hit my top of
my heel Tom you understand that he goes
boom goes home okay tried to stop
so go I'm not trying to aim for her
she's hitting she's hitting me
Oh see she hits me
oh my again home home okay my hands here
look here
right boom I'm pushing it dead he's
triggering me oh I make sure that hands
on me he's not coming up my face okay so
I just borrowed my face you see I'm
doing this not picking it I'm just
parting my face
and here
oh okay so I have them stretched out
right and when I when I lift him up his
chin that's gonna come ever so slightly
back into my palm he'll you understand
so as long as this foot is grounded it's
enough to take it out you see that no I
mean he he just ever so slightly right
even without the groin strike so he goes
bold I keep the extension back with
brown boots he hits a bomb he'll this is
about
okay so there we are you feel to feel
that tension
so I have to displace him so I don't
even hear
this place so the first goes out is the
I gotta face stop okay then my elbows
anchor popped and I Drive top of my head
right on the bridge of his nose
boom I'm going with it yeah don't let it
break you
oh my after that I walked off so I'm
just starting here never protecting my
head
all right thanks Annie keeps booty-ful
in this coffee I'll start my turn right
push again all this part of my turn
right I just don't want my center
challenge so I'm here like this okay
this hand that's on his head it's going
to stay there and the other hand is
going to come around I can throw a math
time master a strike I'm going to come
up and grab his whole head and his hair
near the front as much as possible if
he's got no hair it doesn't matter
just keep that arm there because this
hand here is going to go into his eye
was it I come from the inside
so he's got his hands underneath me
right I'm here like this I'm going to
keep his hands there by keeping his head
down and I come around here see okay and
now I'm just starting to get and you'll
tap out tap out with your hands proper
better don't let it go too far
hold right is to hand out the head on
the hand off the head that I want to
come around
mmm bull I'm starting to hang the right
and driving now if he has hair I'm going
to take his head and use my elbow I knew
his back until they take his base their
time
works this way
yeah yeah okay he doesn't he doesn't
have hair so I'm going to use my whole
lot on my hand
I'll use my whole arm he was nobody
doesn't have hair I'm still gonna try to
anchor that elbow there keep the on your
face but this hands pushing in this
hands holy and that's to hold that
bottom still hold his head